it's Star Wars season with Star Wars
Battlefront 2 and Star Wars the last
Jedi in this video we're going to be
talking about how Star Wars Battlefront
2 connects to the Star Wars movies and
the wider universe but if you want the
movie focus stuff you need to go to our
sister channel GameSpot universe because
if you like the games you obviously like
the movies right you just like the Star
Wars games that you don't shut up star
wars battlefront 2 story attempts to
bridge the 30 year gap between the
finale of Return of the Jedi and the
start of the force awakens and to help
connect those two stories we have a new
protagonist commander I'd amber Co we'll
be talking about the whole story and all
of its threads in this video so
naturally there will be massive spoilers
this video is more focused on how
Battlefront 2 sits in the Star Wars
universe but if you want to learn about
the main protagonist item versio herself
we have a whole video dedicated to a
backstory over on GameSpot universe
while you're there why don't you make
sure to subscribe for a whole load of
Star Wars the last Jedi coverage in the
run-up to the film's release this
December instead of us recapping the
story of Star Wars Battlefront 2 we're
gonna be focusing on how it connects to
the wider universe the movies and even
some of the books and we might actually
get some hints on what we might see in
Star Wars the last Jedi but before that
we have to go all the way back to the
Battle of Endor
bow front - kicks off with item being
taken captive aboard rebel cruise of the
invincible faith being aboard the ship
is by design whoever she's there to
destroy an intercepted message detailing
the Imperial movements around Endor
which you know was probably ultimately
fruitless as the Death Star still goes
now that super stardestroyer that
Garrick versio watches crash into the
surface the Death Star belongs to
Admiral firmest Piett you remember him
the guy who watches his colleague get
choked out via space Skype gives
numerous reports to Vader himself called
bounty hunter scum notices that it's an
older code sir but it checks out and
finally dies with an earring smashes
into his Star Destroyers bridge and
causes it to crash into the Death Star
obviously the second Death Star being
destroyed is a pretty pivotal moment in
the Star Wars canon as well as being a
cracking ending to the Return of the
Jedi but it also sets in motion the
changes in which item versus character
goes through in Battlefront 2 when she
reports the Inferno squad are extracting
from Endor the Admiral mentions that
they have new orders from Vice Admiral
Sloan a character who was first
introduced in the novel Star Wars and
new dawn after the escape from Endor
iDEN learns of the emperor's death and
his final command of operation cinder
the droid that delivers the message is
reminiscent of the Royal Guard that
would accompany the Emperor in the
original trilogy but the message it
slivers sets into play the rest of the
battlefront 2 story fast forward a few
missions later an agent Miko is sent to
the planet pilio to destroy one of the
emperor's secret servitor ease the
planet was first mentioned in the book
the legends of Luke Skywalker in a story
named the starship graveyard but this is
its first physical appearance and the
Star Wars Canon it's claim that shortly
after the battle of jakku a scavenger
gifted Skywalker a compass however as we
play through the mission as Luke who
meets Miko while stuck an insect amber
we know that Miko allows Skywalker to
take the compass from the observatory
after their time together this compass
the league finds here mate hint a
journey that he and Ray shared during
the last Jedi we know this because the
compass or at least something that looks
a lot like it has made an appearance on
a promotional display for some Star Wars
hot toys the ready user my Kindle has
handily shared the display shows old man
Luke holding on to an item that looks a
lot like the compass he finds on pilio
but we'll have to wait until we see the
movie before we could fully understand
this link to the wider Star Wars Canon
in the next mission Inferno Squad is
tasked with rescuing Protectorate Gleb
stupid name from the planet Varro's
while it's being Mumbai did by Imperial
satellite fire Gleb served as the
headmaster of the future Imperial
leaders military preparatory school on
bardos teaching the notion that
Imperials don't make friends they make
allies it's during grabs rescue that
Miko and versio go against Imperial
orders and get branded as outcasts upon
escaping they realize them as warm
rebels of the crimes the Imperial forces
are committing against their own people
in operation cinder effectively joined
the rebel forces as they assist them by
flying x-wings over Naboo and fighting
in the Battle of Theed alongside
Princess Leia good work out there but
I'd expect nothing less from Inferno
squad fans of the franchise will know
that Naboo is the homeworld
Emperor Palpatine and during the
missions we get to see the same palatial
landscapes of a prominent feature in
Episode one the Phantom Menace
here the story jumps a few months and
the action picks up with a now fully
bearded Han Solo in the familiar planet
takodana in the familiar location of
mass's palace hands objective is to get
information for an imperial turncoat
information that could help liberate you
back as home planet of Kashyyyk which is
currently an imperial controlled world
where they use wiki's as labor during
the book trilogy aftermath rebel forces
are able to liberate the planet of
Kashyyyk now it's this information that
han and chewie get from pal dora that
enabled them to actually deliver that
information and setting course the chain
of events that helped liberate the
planet from the empire later we also get
to see more of Bespin which fans will
know as the location of Cloud City from
the Empire Strikes Back which after the
destruction the Death Star is being used
as a refueling Depot for imperial star
destroyers another planet the star wars
fans will recognize is Sullust the first
appearance was in the Nintendo 64 game
Star Wars Rogue Squadron but its first
canonical appearance was in Star Wars
the Clone Wars and was also a level in
the previous Star Wars Battlefront the
lava-covered landscape contains an
imperial arms Depot that general
collision and danger Lee - rib destroy
the knock-on effect of this is that the
Imperial fleet above Jackie becomes
underpowered and vulnerable to attack
which gives Admiral Ackbar and the rest
of the rebel fleet a handy opportunity
to take advantage of one of the most
interesting connections though is during
the battle of jakku the destruction in
the Imperial fleet during this conflict
is why the jakku desert becomes a
graveyard of spacefaring vessels both
big small is what allows the scavenger
economy to exist and by extension allows
rey to survive by scavenging in the lead
up to the force awakens the character of
the game show a look at the fall of the
Galactic Empire as Star Destroyers fall
to the planet but here the game jumps a
couple of decades del Miko and item
versio Marian have a daughter
the two decades later del is back on
pilio all alone he's trapped by
Protectorate gleb which is still a
stupid name just as kylo Ren and his
first border troops arrive on the planet
del Miko has information on the location
of the maps of Luke Skywalker and it's
revealed that los Antica
the old man from the start of the force
awakens took the map to bay or at some
point it's interesting to note that Gleb
is working on something called project
resurrection
now that could hinter something else
that we may see in the last Jedi now
that she has the support of the first
order and it's at this point this story
ends with a dead mekong starship Corvis
being used to draw our older item versio
to the planet a cliffhanger that will
hopefully get some closure on when the
DLC drops but star wars battlefront 2
seems to have as many hints to the
Future the franchise as it does
connections to the media to preceded it
we'll just have to wait for a month for
the last Jedi and the DLC to drop to
learn more thank you for watching this
deep dive into how star wars battlefront
2 fits into the wider Star Wars canon
now if you're as excited about Star Wars
last year as I am then make sure you
head over to my sister site GameSpot
universe for all your rad movie content
until then subscribe to Gabe's about
universe you will